CRISPY: Hello, and welcome to
the "Google TV Developers
Office Hours," Halloween
edition.
I'm your host today, Crispy, and
I have with me Christian.
As well, we have Les Vogel,
and a special guest today.
Leon, why don't you introduce
yourself.
LEON NICHOLLS: My name is Leon
Nicholls, and most people know
me for being the developer
of Able Remote.
CRISPY: Cool.
So before we actually jump into
your demo, a few things
that we're going to go over.
I have some news.
As our new format goes forward,
I'm introducing
little bits of news.
The first and foremost, I think
is on everybody's mind
right now, the hurricane.
Hurricane Sandy, that struck New
York recently, and kindly
flooded out the subway system.
So if you're in New York,
we feel for you.
Hopefully it's not affecting
your Google
TV development efforts.
On completely unrelated news,
LG U+ has brought IPTV with
Google TV to Korea.
This launched October 15, and
I believe we had Psy as part
of the promotional campaign
for that.
CHRISTIAN: Yes, we did.
CRISPY: So a little bit of
"Gangnam Style" going on.
No, I will not break into
dance right now.
That comes for later.
What else is in the news?
We have--
Logitech has finally gotten
a Play Store update.
So those of you with Logitech
reviews and you're developing
on it, now if you have applied
the latest OTA which has gone
out, you should see the
newer Play Store,
which is kind of cool.
And I guess last in my news
items, I have Hisense has put
together a website announcing
their spiffy new device.
You can check that out.
I'll put the link in the show
notes afterwards, but for
those who want to dive in and
check it right now, you can go
to hisense-usa.com/ pulse/--
P-U-L-S-E slash.
And you can see all the details
about their new and
upcoming device.
So that brings us into our
newer segment, called
Interesting Ideas.
And the first thing I want to
talk about in Interesting
Ideas this week is home
screen replacements.
This is something that
I've started to look
at a lot more recently.
I've been toying around
with this at home.
And there's actually a Google
TV home screen replacement I
found in the Google Play
Store recently.
I don't know how
good it is yet.
I haven't played with it, but
I like the momentum, I like
the direction that
it's going in.
So if you want to check that
out, the one that I'm
referring to is FREEdi Channels
for Google TV, and
it's by MicroMacro Mobile, Inc.
So you should be able to
find that in the Play Store.
It looks like a really good V1
of home screen replacement.
So that's something I would
highly encourage you guys to
check out, and maybe consider
writing your own home screen
replacement.
So that's the first part of
the Interesting Ideas.
The second part is, Leon, I want
to to hand over to you,
so that way you can demo the
really cool thing that you
shared with us earlier
in the week.
LEON NICHOLLS: So I'll post
the YouTube link on the
Google+ page for now.
So if somebody wants to go and
look at that, it gives you an
introduction to what I'm
talking about now.
But basically, I got myself a
Raspberry Pi recently, and I'm
trying to create a home
automation infrastructure for
myself, which includes
controlling my Google TV.
Now to do that at the moment,
there's code available from
Google, but it's all
Android-based.
So I'm not running Android on
my Raspberry Pi yet, maybe
sometime soon.
But I'm running Java on here,
and I wanted to have a way to
control my Google TV
just using Java.
So I took the Anymote library
and removed all the Android
dependencies, and made
them all pure
Java, and got it working.
So now there is a library that
allows you to write Java
programs that can control
your Google TV.
And I'm running it on a
Raspberry Pi, but you can
really run it anywhere
via the 1.6 JRE.
From a desktop, or Windows, or
Mac OSX if you wanted to.
There might be some interesting
things you could
do with that.
So for myself, I'm trying to
do some kind of automation
thing, which would include
switching on the devices
connected to the Google
TV device.
And this sis just the the
first step of it.
So after you watch the video,
you can also go and
play with the code.
I've open sourced the library
so that anybody can go and
write their own Java programs,
and control their Google TV,
maybe do some interesting
projects.
As a follow-up on this first
open source library, I'm also
going to make a version that
should run on the Android.
Kind of bringing it
back home again.
Because obviously, there would
be some interesting
applications for second-screen
apps beyond just the scripting
opportunities from
the Java library.
Now in terms of the
functionality, anything you
can do with your physical Google
TV remote, you can do
with this Java library.
And you can do anything
programmatically.
So once you get past the
[? hearing ?] stage, from
there on, you can write
everything in code.
You don't actually have
to have a using
place for the user.
And so you could do some
interesting automated stuff
with that
CRISPY: So what do you see as a
typical automation scenario?
LEON NICHOLLS: Well, for
example, the first thing I do
in the morning is I switch
on the TV, and I go
to a certain channel.
So rather than doing that by
going through the remote, I
can do that by maybe having a
sensor that picks up when I'm
just walking through the room
and switch on the TV for me.
That's a simple scenario.
You could go to your favorite
channel, or go to your
favorite website, maybe
look at the weather.
There's all kinds of things
you can do with that.
The other thing is that it's
not just about Google TV.
It's nice that you can control
the other devices.
You can control your AVR,
you can control your CD.
So for example, I could
switch it on to play
some music for me.
So that's really nice.
It gives me control over
things which is kind of
complicated for me to do by
myself, if I didn't have the
Google TV device support.
CRISPY: So you see this is an
extension of home automation,
and something you
could set up.
Hey, you turn your key in your
front door, and automatically
your TV comes on and maybe
it's controlling
other things too, then.
LEON NICHOLLS: Yeah, yeah.
So this is the first
part of it.
I've already started on the
second part, which will be a
more full-fledged component
of what the final
solution will be.
But this is just one
simple case.
You could also write your
own desktop app.
If you wanted to have maybe a
Google TV GUI on your desktop
computer, you could write
one with this.
It's very easy to add [? GUI ?]
using the interface.
The library was specifically
designed to be independent of
the user interface.
Let's say you want to use
JavaSwing to make your own UI,
you can go ahead and do that.
And so there's some interesting
use cases to just
use it as a remote
or separately.
CRISPY: So what made you choose
the Raspberry Pi over,
say, Arduino or Netduino, or
any of the of the other
multiboards that have
come out recently?
LEON NICHOLLS: Oh, I've got a
pile of Arduinos here, too.
This just happens to be the
coolest thing at the moment.
It is really, really very
interesting to see at at this
price point what you can do.
It really is incredible, and
there's a lot of really
interesting stuff happening in
that form, in terms of, not
just Linux, but other OSes that
will be available for
this [INAUDIBLE] soon,
including Android.
You can run it at the moment,
it's extremely slow, but the
Raspberry Pi [INAUDIBLE]
Foundation are working on
an optimized version.
So that could be very
interesting, to have Android
running on here.
Just imagine all kinds of
automation-type things, and
you can write it all in the
same programming language.
You don't have to even go to
Java if you wanted to.
But yeah, it's one little toy
that's part of a bigger idea
that I have for doing stuff
as a side project.
CRISPY: Cool.
So if people want to see what
you've done, or contribute, or
ask you questions, how
can they do that?
LEON NICHOLLS: Well I think the
best is to contact me via
the GitHub source control.
And if there's any questions
about that--
Or otherwise, just
through Google+.
Should be able to contact
me, I'll send a
message or an email.
CRISPY: OK.
LEON NICHOLLS: Some developers
have alreadt indicated they're
interested in it because there's
certain things they
want to do that they can't do
Anymote library at the moment.
So there might be something
interesting coming from other
developers, too.
CRISPY: Cool.
Well, we'll post in the show
notes where to access the
source code and how to view the
demo video that you put
together that unfortunately
we couldn't
show through the Hangout.
And if anybody has questions for
Leon now, live, I guess we
can take them.
Otherwise, we're going to move
on to a discussion topic that
Christian and I both found
very interesting.
I think we've spent many hours
talking about this.
CHRISTIAN: Oh, I have spent
years by now talking about
this at various events.
It's actually interesting, two
weekends ago, I was in Texas
at the big Android barbecue.
And there was a lot of Android
developers, and I was actually
struck again how many developers
still don't fully
utilize things like display
independent pixels or know
about Android DPIs or things
like NinePatch Images.
So for some developers, this is
really super-intuitive, for
others it's not.
CRISPY: I guess we should
introduce the topic.
You kind of went
right into it.
So there are Stack Overflow
questions
that come up regularly.
One of the ones that I pulled
out today, I'm just going to
read it verbatim.
"I started writing a
Google TV app and
DisplayMetrics.widthPixels
equaled 1,804, and
heightPixels equaled 1,008, and
densityDpI was set to 320.
Has anyone got a setup for the
graphical layout editor,
because I can't use WYSIWYG,
et cetera.
Problems dealing with, hey, the
screen size isn't what I
expected, and the resolution
isn't quite what I was
expecting."
So there are two main DPIs, the
213 DPI, and the 320 DPI.
But with overscan, if a user
hasn't configured their Google
TV properly or at all, or their
screen resolution is
kind of weird because they've
got a low-grade screen that
they've attached it to, you
might not end up with the same
DPI that you expect or
the same number of
device-independent pixels
as you expect.
CHRISTIAN: Well, actually, the
DPI is not going to change.
So the DPI is a function of 720p
versus 1080p resolution.
CRISPY: Oh, that's right.
Yes.
CHRISTIAN: What is going to
change is the total available
pixels on-screen.
And as Crispy pointed out,
unfortunately, even today with
digital televisions, there's
still overscan.
Some TVs, depending on the
settings, do not display the
full 1920 by 1080 pixels
on the screen.
So as a platform, we basically
have two choices.
We could always output from an
Android point of view, a
full-screen, 1080p image, but
then each individual developer
would have to deal with
the overscan.
That is, for example, extremely
bad when you have
icons that are on the top or
bottom of the screen, or left
or right of the screen.
So the decision that Google TV
made, a few years ago now, is
to compensate for the overscan
by giving the user an option
to adjust the screen size to
match the physical, available,
screen size.
And that can result in your
application running on Google
TV, which has fewer than
1920 by 1080 pixels.
CRISPY: The device-independent
pixel count--
CHRISTIAN: So the
device-independent pixel count
for 1080p is exactly half of
the physical pixel count.
So on a full high-resolution
display, you
would get 960 by 540.
If you have overscan,
then it can be less.
It can be 920 or 900
or sometimes even
800 by 450 or something.
I don't know what the minimum
is we support.
But right now, at least, the
display-independent pixels are
identical between
720 and 1080.
So if you switch resolutions,
that does not change.
And as Crispy's alluded, we have
constantly discussions in
the office, trying to improve
and trying to see how we can
make life easier
for developers.
So I think one of the
discussions that we've had
recently, and that I want to
just throw out to developers
is, is it actually a good idea
to have those numbers that we
have today, the 213
and the 240?
CRISPY: So we want to open
it up to you guys,
since you're here.
Let's discuss this
a little bit.
If anybody has strong opinions
about it, or ideas--
CHRISTIAN: Do people actually
use display-independent
pixels, or is this
something that--
Yeah.
So Leon is familiar with it.
CRISPY: And just to be aware,
I've muted everybody, so you
might have to unmute before
you can talk.
LEON NICHOLLS: Yeah, so,
although UI on the TV at the
moment is very basic, we have to
put that in because one of
the things we did for our app
was to submit it to Sony to be
a featured app.
And they actually have a bunch
of tests, which includes
running it at the lowest
or the most extreme
case for the borders.
And so the first thing was, we
had to make sure we had to do
the DOD stuff correctly, but
secondly, we had to make sure
that even with all the edges
cut off, that all the text
specifically was visible.
That's something we hadn't done
originally with the app.
CHRISTIAN: Yeah.
So one of the side effects of
what we have right now with
320 DPI is that the screen size
effectively, as I said,
is 960 by 540.
That is actually fewer DPs than
what you would expect,
for example, even on a tablet.
So most tablets today
have 1200 by 720.
So one of the the ideas that I'm
toying around with is if,
for example, hypothetically,
we would change the DPIs to
240, we would arrive
at more DPs--
CRISPY: 1280 by 720.
CHRISTIAN: Yeah, we would have
1280 by 720 on the screen.
A side effect is, the fonts
would get smaller.
So I think it's sort of a
trade off between giving
developers more real estate on
the screen, or of course then
shrinking, relatively
speaking--
CRISPY: Every other
application.
CHRISTIAN: --all
the other apps.
So I don't know.
Leon, do you feel when you
develop for Google TV, or
anybody else on the video, do
you actually run out of DPs?
Do you sometimes wish you would
have more DPs available?
Or, for example, to transfer
your tablet
layouts more easier?
LEON NICHOLLS: I think it's
going to become maybe more of
an issue as people develop
tablet apps and want to also
do it for the TV.
Because you're very aware
of this issue on the TV.
That's kind of one issue.
The other issue is it's almost
the reverse of it.
The fact that you have less DPs
actually help you think
about the TV experience
in a better way.
To not fill the space with
everything, and not to have
the same experience as you would
have on a mobile phone
or a tablet.
To really think about using
the space, but not try and
fill it with everything.
So I think it's probably
more of a norm
on the mobile devices.
So in a way, it helps, but it's
something I think most
developers don't think of
when they go to the TV.
And so maybe there is something
still not quite
right about the process.
CHRISTIAN: Yeah.
I also think sometimes we have
to keep in mind with Google TV
becoming more international,
and as Crispy said, we just
had a very successful launch in
Korea, in other countries,
people actually have smaller TVs
and smaller living rooms
in general.
So we've seen, for example in
Korea, what we call the
10-foot experience here in the
US, it's really more like a
5-foot experience.
People sit closer to the TV,
but then they only have
instead of a 60-inch television,
they have a
35-inch television.
CRISPY: Localization plays a
big role in this as well.
I guess it wouldn't make sense
to give some sort of mode
control to the developer,
then.
We kind of have it already, with
720p and 1080p, and we've
abstracted that away
with the 965/40.
But imagine if there was some
programmatic way to--
say I want to use the high
granularity mode, or low
granularity mode to get those
different densities.
I don't know, maybe it would
just add to the confusion in
the layouts, though.
CHRISTIAN: One of the ideas
we've tossed around here was,
right now, the reason we have
213 DPs is so that when you
switch to 720p, the number
of DPs stays constant.
So the ratio is exactly
the same as the
screen resolution ratio.
So if we would go to just, for
example, 240, but keep 240 for
both 720 and for 1080, then we
would end up with a situation
where you have, relatively
speaking, more screen real
estate on a 1080 screen
versus a 720 screen.
That might be one idea.
The other thing that I've
started to think about in my
back of my mind is also 4K
screens, which are coming.
CRISPY: I think we're still at
least half a decade to a full
decade away from
realizing that.
I mean, yes, the market's
accelerating but personally, I
don't think the 4K screens are
going to make an appearance
anytime soon.
People are just getting into--
CHRISTIAN: I know.
CRISPY: --the space that
we have today.
LEON NICHOLLS: The other fact
is as you get higher DPs, of
course your resources grow.
And it's [? expert ?] dramatic,
especially when you
view the images.
And specifically on Google TV,
since the storage space is
quite limited, you can't really
go crazy on that site.
CRISPY: It's 96 megabytes of
RAM, I think, is allocated per
running application.
LEON NICHOLLS: So that is
something you probably going
to run in quite quickly when
you want to do high-res
graphics at a high DP.
CHRISTIAN: Sometimes developers
or users forget
that when the resolution
doubles, your
screen assets quadruple.
LEON NICHOLLS: Yeah,
it's scary.
CHRISTIAN: Square of the size.
All right.
So I would say in the comments,
let's just keep the
conversation going.
I'm curious about input
from developers who
actually use DPs.
And give us your feedback.
Let us know if this is something
that you think works
just fine, or if you struggle
with it, if you have any other
ideas, stuff you've thought
about, let us know.
CRISPY: We're in the planning
stages for future work.
So the other thing that we
have going on for today's
Hangout, if I can find
the window now.
LEON NICHOLLS: Sorry, guys, can
I just make a suggestion
in terms of this
DP discussion?
Could we have a topic
in the tracker?
Because then people can add
their comments there, and we
can all look at the
same comments.
With Issue Tracker.
CRISPY: Issue Tracker?
Yeah, that works.
CHRISTIAN: Or Google+ thing.
LEON NICHOLLS: Yeah, just
somewhere we can see the
thread, because otherwise it's
just all independent kind of
discussion.
CRISPY: Right.
I kind of like the Issue Tracker
one because I think it
would also increase
the visibility.
So do you want to create
the issue, Leo?
LEON NICHOLLS: Sure.
CRISPY: Awesome.
All right, so, we have
two [? Dory ?]
questions.
And just to let everyone know
who's tuning in now or at a
later time through YouTube at
our channel there, I've
started to limit the time period
that people can add
questions to the moderator.
Typically I'm going to be
opening it up on the Monday at
2:00 PM before the Wednesday
Hangout, and then the
moderator closes off
at the time that we
start the Hangout itself.
So there's two questions here,
but I've also taken the
liberty of searching through
Stack Overflow to find some
what I consider interesting
questions that I think we
could talk or discuss
a little bit.
So let's start with the
moderator and then we can
migrate into the Stack
Overflow questions.
LES VOGEL: Yeah, Crispy There's
also one on the thread.
CRISPY: On the thread?
I have too many channels of
information coming at me.
LES VOGEL: It's basically asking
about the Google+ App
optimized for Google TV.
CRISPY: Ah.
The Google+ App optimized
for Google TV.
The only answer that I can say
is, I have nothing to announce
at this time.
I should have worn
that shirt today.
I mean, that's just a
scary as my costume.
So it is Halloween, for those
who are tuning in or like, why
is this guy dressed
up this way?
I'm wearing my circa 1991
Russian military general
uniform with some KGB symbols
here, so I'm the spooky former
military commander
on campus here.
MALE SPEAKER: You have
no red on you.
CRISPY: I've got red.
You just can't see it here.
I've also got with me--
what military costume wouldn't
be complete without a flask
full of vodka?
MALE SPEAKER: Excellent.
CRISPY: Excellent, yes.
No, we're not going to
be drinking on the
Hangout right now.
CHRISTIAN: We'll save that
for the afternoon.
CRISPY: We'll save that for
the after party, yeah.
All right, let's jump into these
moderator questions and
keep the pace going.
"The documentation for the
GTV emulator located at
developers.googl
e.com/tv/android
/docs/gtv_emulator says 'You
cannot run the GTV emulator on
Windows.' Is this true?
When will GTV emulation be
available on Windows?" So Les,
you can start, and I
will add things.
LES VOGEL: Real soon.
CRISPY: OK.
That's the shortest answer
I think I've heard
you give in a while.
LES VOGEL: I sometimes
give those.
The 212 emulator should be out
in a few days or a week.
CRISPY: Stay tuned.
It's coming.
For those of you who are using
the emulator, there's a few
things that I feel are important
to point out.
And they are as follows.
One, with the emulator, you
do not get full device
compatibility.
There's no HDMI in,
you don't have
access to mDNS and Anymote.
It's in its own little space,
there are hacks and
work-arounds.
I highly recommend that any
developer who's building for
Google TV, get a Google
TV device.
They're really not that
expensive, and if you're
investing the time to develop,
you should do it
with the real hardware.
You'll have a much smoother time
transitioning into the
space, I think.
CHRISTIAN: Also, I think it's
really important if you create
an application for the living
room, you need to use it in
the living room, and
you need to try it.
It's a very different
environment than creating an
app in an emulator
on a desktop.
I think the emulator
has its place for
some limited UI testing.
One other thing that does not
work in the emulator, really,
is multimedia.
And I think a lot of TV
applications should include
streaming video, streaming
audio, which is really not
very well simulated
in the emulator.
CRISPY: Right.
Well, you're in that mindset,
I've heard this a few times.
You're sitting at your desk.
You don't have a TV on your
desk, so you're like, well,
what can I use so I can
keep my flow going.
And the emulator seems to make
sense, but it's a stop-gap for
only solving certain types
of development
problems in the space.
The other thing I hear a lot is,
can I connect the Google
TV device to an HDMI monitor?
You can, but the monitor has
to support HDCP, which not
everybody realizes
or understands.
So it can be a bit of a pain,
but maybe bring your laptop
into your living room and code
that way, that works.
I mean, we put TVs
on our desks.
That's not practical for
everybody but it does get you
farther than the
emulator will.
At least from a real development
case, and keeps
you in the right user
headspace, I think.
CHRISTIAN: Yeah, also the remote
control is critical.
On an emulator, you
use the keyboard.
LES VOGEL: Really,
performance.
And frankly, a real
box is only $99.
MALE SPEAKER: The question came
from me, and I'm trying
to get other people
interested.
And if we can use the emulator
as sort of a lower platform
for getting people in, they can
say, ooh, this is cool, I
think I'll go out
and spend $99.
And it sounds like in a couple
weeks or soon, it's going to
be a non-issue, so whoo-hoo!
CRISPY: If it's run on Windows,
according to Les, yes.
But nothing will substitute
the real device.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, and
you saw my comment.
I tried doing the debug with
the hardware device.
It worked when I first got it,
but I'm on a different PC, on
a different sub-net, and it
just got all confused.
I've only spent 20 minutes
playing with it, so I could
probably get something
to work.
I don't really care, but my goal
was, if here's easy ways
for people to start playing.
CRISPY: OK.
So maybe as you uncover those,
and figure out your workflow,
I would highly encourage you to
maybe do some screencasts,
and possibly post those
to your blog.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm way behind on
the billions of screencasts
I'm supposed to do, but it's
on my list, trust me.
CRISPY: Awesome.
LEON NICHOLLS: In our
experience, using the device
is really the way to go.
We spent some time with the
emulator, but you end up
running into a problem pretty
soon no matter what kind of
app you do.
And it's so easy,
it's so fast.
Once you've set it up, it is
really the fastest way of
developing, so if you want to
be the most productive in
writing Google TV apps,
use a device.
MALE SPEAKER: That's what I
did when I first started
playing with it.
You may not know, my app is
to get app inventors to
work with Google TV.
I've got that solved, now it's
to get the app-inventor users
to use the compiler to generate
Google TV ads.
And for that, I'm just trying
to lower the entrance.
Once they get in, I assume
that they'll
do reasonable things.
CRISPY: OK.
It's a little hairy to set up,
but I'm encouraged by what
you're doing, so hopefully you
can figure out how to get
traction and let us know
how that goes.
I'm going to move us on to the
next question, just to keep
things flowing here.
"What's the best component
to mount a
horizontal list for TV?
So HorizontalScrollView,
custom GridView, View,
ViewPager, or other?"
This is from Brazil.
Everybody goes silent.
CHRISTIAN: Horizontal list.
CRISPY: So I think what they're
asking is what's the
best component--
CHRISTIAN: It's a
gallery view.
CRISPY: --for a gallery view.
LES VOGEL: I know, I know, but
I can't talk about it.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRISTIAN: It's just
rectangles, Les.
CRISPY: It's just rectangles,
nothing more.
LES VOGEL: The rectangles,
exactly.
CRISPY: So I'm going to say,
I'm a big fan of OpenGL.
So you could really go crazy
and create your own custom
widget with OpenGL surfaces
and loading images.
LES VOGEL: Yes!
CRISPY: Oh, Les is championing
that one.
Christian here is cringing
beside me and sighing, so,
what's your take?
CHRISTIAN: Yeah, I think OpenGL
is actually fairly easy
if you just have bitmaps
and stuff.
So it's not rocket science.
What I would say is, if you want
to stick with Android,
just HorizontalScrollView
works fine.
The focus issues are sometimes
a little bit tricky, so you
may have to override your
focus handling.
CRISPY: OK.
Anybody else want to add
anything to that?
LES VOGEL: That sounds right.
CRISPY: All right.
So with that, we'll move on to
the Stack Overflow questions
that I pulled aside here.
And these ones, again,
these are not in
any specific priority.
I went looking through the list,
and these are the ones
that caught my eye.
So I have one [? Vinnie ?]
asked, "I'm trying to run Google
TV Maps example on the
Google TV Emulator.
I'm facing an issue, as the
emulator does not contain the
Google Maps application that
apparently is required to run.
Does Google TV support
Google Maps?"
CHRISTIAN: Yes.
CRISPY: Yeah, it does.
But not as in a Maps
application.
LES VOGEL: The Maps
API is supported.
There's sample code called
Maps On TV, that's open
sourced, and it's in Market.
And you can build it
and play with it.
CRISPY: Right.
And if you wanted to add
Maps directly into your
application, you could always
use the Maps API directly.
LES VOGEL: Right.
That's what Maps [INAUDIBLE].
So and [? ByBob ?] wrote that.
CRISPY: So [? Vinnie, ?]
hopefully you will see that
and make some progress with
the app you're building.
Another question from
[? Terraloca. ?]
"Is there a way to grab the lat
and long that corresponds
to the zip code the user
supplied when setting up their
Google TV box?" Yes, there is.
What you want to do is use the
Get System service, asking for
the location service, which
will give you a Location
Manager object, that you can
then ask the Location Manager
object for the Get Last Known
Location "static".
And that will return a location
object to you that
you can then get the
lat and long from.
You will also need to add the
user's permission for
android.permissi
on.accesscourselocation.
I believe this stuff is all
covered in the base Android
API documentation.
So the trick here from Google TV
is when requesting the last
known location, the string you
want to pass in there is
lowercase static.
All right?
LEON NICHOLLS: Just one comment
on that, it only
works in the US.
CRISPY: Only works in the US.
CHRISTIAN: That was
my comment, too.
CRISPY: Oh, right.
Because zip code, here, right.
OK.
What could you do in Europe?
LES VOGEL: I think it also works
in Korea on the LGU+.
CRISPY: So if somebody wanted
location, not in the US or
Korea, what do you think
they should do?
LEON NICHOLLS: Well, we had to
go and find another way of
mapping an IP address
to a location.
We couldn't rely on
the Google TV API.
CRISPY: So did you
use, what, just a
third-party IP to do a lookup?
LEON NICHOLLS: There
are services.
And the good ones you have
to pay for, so you
can't get it for free.
MALE SPEAKER: Would the
IP be reliable?
It seems like that wouldn't get
you a real good address,
it would just get you
a maybe address.
LEON NICHOLLS: You have
to dig around.
There are some that
are better.
So I actually went through a
whole bunch of them to find
ones that looked reasonably
accurate.
But even then, you have to keep
updating the database
behind that to make sure that
you have an accurate mapping.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm trying to be
polite, and my answer was
going to be stand there with
your phone and get the
lat/long on your phone
and click it over.
But I decided that wasn't
a good answer.
LES VOGEL: That's actually not
a bad answer, if you think
about it, and think about
second screen design.
But Leon, as I remember, you pay
for the database and you
have to set up your
own server.
Was that what you did?
LEON NICHOLLS: Various things.
There are some that actually
provide a service.
Obviously, you pay
for that service.
But yeah, typically, you grab a
copy of the database and put
it on your own server.
And then you need to keep
the database updated.
So there's a fee that you pay
to have the latest database.
MALE SPEAKER: Now that you've
brought it up, the second
screen is what I was really
going to say, eventually.
Anybody that sets up a Google
TV that wants lat/long
probably has a computer down the
road, just sitting in the
other room, if not
any place else.
And I'm wondering if, as people
start seeing Google TV
less as a device and more as a
screen that's hooked up to
your other screens, or who knows
running where, then it
will be reasonable
to, oh, lat/long.
I can't get it here, but
I can get it over here.
LEON NICHOLLS: I guess the only
issue is that now your
mobile app would have to add
the permissions for getting
the location, and that might
be a little bit unusual for
some users.
They might just ask why you
make stuff like that.
LES VOGEL: Well, you
just explained it.
I mean, that's part of what you
should be doing in Google
Play is explaining what
your permissions
are, if they're unusual.
And why you get them, and how
specifically you use them.
That's the recommendation
that the Android team
has given, at least.
CRISPY: So there are ways to
mitigate users and what they
think is acceptable and
not acceptable.
All right, I'm going to move
us on to the next question.
Somebody asked this and I
thought it was a great
question to ask because I think
we've covered it once or
twice but we've got some
better answers now.
"Which resource identifier can
I use for Google TVs to
distinguish it from phones like
Galaxy S3, et cetera?
Apparently 'Layout-SW 720
DP' doesn't work".
So I took this on as like,
hey, what does work?
And at first, I'd always just
used Layout because I'm
usually just writing Google
TV apps, but then I tried
creating one that would run on
a tablet, a phone, and a TV.
And I put TV-specific
resources in
Layout-television, which is a
new layout that was introduced
in 3.2 of Android.
And that worked fine until
I created another layout
directory or Layout-Large-No
Touch.
And apparently the precedents
of Layout-Large-No Touch
supersedes that of
Layout-Television.
CHRISTIAN: Have you
actually tried
Layout-Television-No Touch?
CRISPY: I did not
try that one.
CHRISTIAN: We should
CRISPY: We should
try that one.
Although TV by itself would
never have touch.
CHRISTIAN: But the matching
algorithm probably takes-- it
matches more criteria.
CRISPY: OK, yeah we'll
try that one out.
LES VOGEL: Since you probably
want the longer stream.
CRISPY: Yeah, OK.
I was recently reading the
precedence rules for how
Android decides which layout
directory to use for which
resources to load.
And that's some complicated
stuff.
It's like regex stuff,
only on steroids.
LES VOGEL: Hey, Crispy, do you
know the answer of how to
determine which box you're on?
A Sony or--
CRISPY: What is the
current device?
The manufacturing device?
LES VOGEL: Vizio?
CRISPY: Not yet, but if you
really want to know some of
that info, you could potentially
go to the
user-agent string from Chrome.
CHRISTIAN: Well, there is a
properties and settings class.
So I've actually dug in there
around yesterday because I
needed to find something.
And you can get build
information, you can even get
what's the current build
number that you're
running, and so on.
CRISPY: Oh, so all the stuff
that shows up in status.
Gotcha.
CHRISTIAN: So Les, do you know,
I would have to look at
my code now, do you know the
class name of [INAUDIBLE]?
LES VOGEL: I don't remember the
class, but I was trying to
find the actual constant
because--
oh, here we are.
We are recommending now that
you use ro.product.model
instead of ro.hardware.
That is going to be very
important in the near future
as how you differentiate
your Google TV box.
So it's ro.product.model.
CHRISTIAN: Yep.
LES VOGEL: So if you need to
know the difference between a
Vizio and a Sony or a Hisense,
that's the way to tell.
CRISPY: All right.
LES VOGEL: And that should also
be if you're trying to
figure out if it's
an LG as well.
CRISPY: I guess we're going to
have to publish a list, or is
it just a discovery thing?
LES VOGEL: We should probably
publish something about that.
But since you brought the
subject, I thought, oh, well,
what about programmatic?
Because I've been meaning
to write something
about this for a while.
CRISPY: All right.
So why don't you start
publishing a list and we'll
add it to the documentation.
LES VOGEL: Yeah.
CRISPY: Cool.
All right, let's move
on to another one.
"I'm looking at integrating
my MythTV with Google TV.
I would like to have the same
level of integration found
with Dish Network DVR, ability
to set things to record from
Google TV, and look
up recordings.
Is there any API that can be
used for this, or is it only
something that Google and Dish
can do via their partnership?"
So the API you are looking for
is talked about in one of our
Google I/O talks called "Getting
your content on
Google TV" and I think it's--
CHRISTIAN: That was my talk.
CRISPY: That was your
talk, that's right.
Well, then you should elaborate
on this, I think.
CHRISTIAN: Well, should.
We've talked about this
API a lot, so it's--
LES VOGEL: Except you're
not going to actually
release it this time.
CHRISTIAN: Exactly, yeah.
CRISPY: Oh, that's right.
LES VOGEL: So this was a bad
question to bring up.
CRISPY: I forgot.
CHRISTIAN: We're still
working on the API.
And I mean, the intention of it
is that we will have an API
for third party developers to
create sort of like a device
driver for your connected
device.
So if you have a device that
talks IP and you know the IP
protocol, then you're
able to include it.
And we're sort of in the process
of finalizing the API.
If somebody would be interested
in talking about
this, let us know, reach me on
Google+, I would be more than
happy to hear your use case,
make sure we can include that.
CRISPY: So we have one, we'll
get that person contacted.
All right, we'll move on
to another question.
Bad selection on my part.
"Does anyone have a reference
to the key codes
for the Sony remote?
I have Play and Stop Working,
but need Pause key codes.
Play and Pause seem to be
referencing the same key code,
but the buttons are separate on
the remotee." So we've got
sone docs on the GTV
controlling guide.
So if you go to
developers.google.com/tv, I
believe if you go /android/docs,
there's a
GTV_control guide with
media key, so it's
all documented there.
And you should be able
to find the key code
you're looking for.
The other thing I would
recommend, Christian wrote
this great app called Screen
Resolution Test.
And yes, the name isn't obvious,
but you can use this
to actually determine the
key codes that get
sent from the remote.
If you install this app and go
into the-- what's the first
one called?
Resolution Test?
CHRISTIAN: I think it's
Resolution Test, yeah.
This is my catch-all application
that I throw all
my demo code and sample code
that I need on TV.
So yeah, I think it's
the first menu.
CRISPY: It's for debugging.
So you can check that out.
I think we mentioned it a few
shows ago as well, so we can
repost the link to that.
What else have I got here?
"Has anyone successfully made a
multi-screen app for Google
TV by using the Google
TV Emulator?
If so, then please guide me in
the right direction." I forgot
I chose many emulator
questions today.
LES VOGEL: Is that why you
bade me get on the line?
CRISPY: Yes, yes it is.
Just to reiterate, Google TV
Emulator does not broadcast as
an any mode endpoint vai MDNS,
so presently it can't be used
for developing multi-screen
apps.
Yeah, I think we've talked about
that enough already.
So I'm going to move us
on to the next one.
"Is it possible to create my own
custom home application on
Google TV?" Yes.
How you do that, it's
very simple.
You can go to the Android
samples directory for API 13,
and look at the homescreen
replacement
example they have there.
It actually runs, as is, on
Google TV, and you can see a
good example of how to
take over the home
screen, as it were.
So you can also check out the
application I recommended at
the beginning, which is FREEdi
channels for Google TV.
It's in the Play Store.
I only took a cursory look at
it, it looked pretty cool.
All right, this was the big
multipart question next.
CHRISTIAN: Oh, I
love that one.
CRISPY: So this one really
caught my attention, because
all the people involved in
asking it and talking about on
Stack Overflow, they all had
reputations in the multiple
thousands, usually
above 15,000.
So I don't know if we've
talked about this stuff
before, but I feel it's worth
bringing up again now.
And I'll just read it verbatim,
and then you guys
can all jump in.
You've already answered
some of this.
CHRISTIAN: There's actually one
part I haven't answered--
the very first question.
CRISPY: The very
first question.
All right, so we'll
start with that.
"First of all, I'm not asking
if it's OK to totally forget
about efficiency when writing an
application for Google TV.
I would never do that.
But I'm still curious, what
are the differences?"
CHRISTIAN: Actually to
the first question.
CRISPY: Oh, that one.
CHRISTIAN: Yeah, first one.
"Is it OK to forget about
performance and efficiency on
Google TV?" I think that's
an absolutely bad idea.
I think Google TV is really
important to be responsive.
People are used to things
moving around on a TV.
Usually when things stop moving
on a TV, people get
nervous, something crashed.
About performance, I know
sometimes it takes a while to,
for example, load assets
from your servers.
Really be very, very conscious
about displaying progress
bars, or some sort of indicator
that yes, I'm
working on it.
Another not-so-favorite mode
that I find in a lot of apps
is using the same key to bring
up and dismiss an action, like
the home screen.
And sometimes users press the
key, nothing happens, they
press it again, and then they
see an activity flash up and
go back away again.
So make sure you give the user
the feedback that, OK yes, I
receive your key press.
I'm working on it, I'm
doing it, stay tuned.
Even if it's just for one or two
seconds, it's a good idea.
There are some really bad
examples out there.
There's some applications which
take literally a minute
or more, initially, downloading
assets and doing things.
In this case, do something
funny.
Just display comic strips or
something, keep the user
entertained.
CRISPY: So the least shock and
constant user feedback.
OK.
Now I'm going to continue
reading this, unless--
LEON NICHOLLS: This is a point
I would recommend that your
[? subtesters ?]
on different Google
TV devices.
We've seen, especially when it
comes to animation, even with
the OpenGL-type animation,
that they do perform
differently on the different
hardware.
And so it would be good to get a
range, low-end device, and a
high-end device to see
something that
will work for both.
And not just assume that people
are going to buy the
high-end devices.
LES VOGEL: A Vizio device or
Hisense device is very
different than an LG, graphics
performance-wise.
CHRISTIAN: Also, for a developer
of the class of
Leon, where you really write
applications for a broad
audience, I would very much
recommend to still test on a
Generation 1 device, on some
of the Intel devices.
Especially with hardware
acceleration, there are some
significant differences.
LES VOGEL: Christian, to your
question earlier, which was
also my comment, so far the only
thing I've been able to
find to get the ro.properties
is to exec with GetProp.
CHRISTIAN: I'll look at
my code in a second.
After the show, I'll post
in the comments.
CRISPY: Maybe we'll post
something, a deeper write-up
or maybe even a streamcast or
blog post or something.
So we'll provide some more
information for that.
So I've only gotten past the
first sentence of this
question and it's already
generated quite a bit of
controver--
well, not controversy--
CHRISTIAN: It's going
to get better.
CRISPY: It's going to get much
better, because this is long.
All right, so "I'm still
curious, what are the
differences between developing
something for Google TV and a
mobile device, such as
a tablet handset?
I found a lot of information
online about the differences
in user interface design, ie TV
is meant to be more social,
no screen orientation, no
touchscreen, et cetera.
But none of the documentation
describes the
hardware-specific differences
between the two devices.
To be more specific, considering
that Android was
originally designed for mobile
devices with limited memory,
is designing an application for
Google TV any different?"
So you started to answer this
one with what you had here, do
you want to read it, do you
want to just say it again?
CHRISTIAN: Let me just make sure
I cover all the topics
here, so I'll glance
at my notes.
But the question was
really whether--
so let me paraphrase this.
Android devices were
very limited,
especially with memory.
Is Google TV any different?
And Google TV is still very
memory-constrained.
We really try to produce
affordable devices.
So right now, Google TV has
about one gigabyte of total
memory, which is shared between
the Dalvik virtual
machine and the hardware
acceleration, video
decoding, and so on.
So ultimately, the Dalvik VM has
about 600 megabytes on our
devices today.
What we have done is, we
have increased the
per-application limit.
So for example on a Galaxy Nexus
phone, each application
gets 64 megabytes
of total memory.
On Google TV, we bumped
it up to 96 megabytes.
And we actually did
some tests.
We initially thought, well,
maybe we should just double it
and go to 128.
But keep in mind, it's a
trade-off between how much
memory each application gets,
and how many applications you
can run at the same time.
So we felt that 96 is a
reasonable compromise.
The reason we actually had
to bump it up is, as Leon
mentioned earlier, screen
resolution has gone up
significantly.
Assets are bigger, resources are
bigger, so just having one
full-screen image for
Google TV is about 8
megabytes of RAM.
So 96 megs is still fairly
constrained.
It's especially noticeable for
people who do things like
loading in a lot
of thumbnails.
So we have some application
developers who, for example,
want to show a library of
movies, and they want to load
cover art for each
of the movie.
And holding all those bitmaps
in memory at the same time,
you run out of memory
pretty quickly.
So it's important that
developers load things on
demand, recycle bitmaps, and
have an overall efficient
programming style.
CRISPY: So you just actually
triggered an interesting
thought in my head.
So if you have a service that
you're running as a separate
process, is it going to get
a separate 96 megs of RAM?
CHRISTIAN: You should.
CRISPY: So in theory,
you could--
I'm not recommending this at all
to anybody, by the way--
you could, in theory, load your
imagery sources and pass
them through as a binary
exchange for display.
CHRISTIAN: Don't do
that [INAUDIBLE].
CRISPY: Don't do what
Crispy does!
He's been drinking.
LES VOGEL: Vodka.
Yeah, that's a good
idea, though.
CRISPY: Anybody else want to add
to that, or shall I move
on to the next part
of the question?
No?
All right.
"So phones and tablets don't
have the luxury of swap space,
and therefore there are
hard limits on memory.
Is this also the case
with Google TV?"
CHRISTIAN: Yes.
CRISPY: So nice simple short
answer, no swap space.
Part Three is, "The Dalvik VM
is optimized for minimal
memory footprint on handsets
and tablets.
Is Google TV powered by the
exact same VM, a slightly
different version designed
specifically for Google TV but
with the same design goal
in mind, or a completely
different VM with different
design goals in mind?"
CHRISTIAN: There have been
rumors that we like to
reimplement stuff
here at Google.
Once we have a virtual machine
that works really well, we
tend to stick with it.
So the Dalvik VM is really
exactly the same virtual
machine, for simply the reason
that the constraints are
exactly the same.
We still have an embedded
system.
We have flash file systems.
We have no swap space, and we
need to be memory efficient.
At same time, of course,
we want to
be as fast as possible.
And we felt that the Dalvik
VM does all this.
On top of it, it already helped
us a lot with the
Intel-to-ARM transition, where
for users who develop Dalvik
code, it's completely
transparent what
processor you run on.
CRISPY: That's another big thing
for device independence.
All right.
Anybody else want to add to that
before I move on to the
next piece?
No?
Awesome.
"What are the actual differences
in hardware when
comparing handsets, tablets,
and Google TV?
Are the differences significant,
other than
touchscreen?"
CHRISTIAN: It's really
stereotypical by now, but I
will mention the touch screen
again, because that is the
biggest difference.
And usually, when I talk with
developers at first, they
dismiss it, and they're
like, oh yeah,
whatever it's super easy.
But you need to redesign
your layouts.
There is a difference between
an app that just barely runs
on a television and an app
that is really a great
experience and is really
optimized.
So this is the most visible
difference, I think.
Once people get going and they
dig deeper into it, probably
the most surprising and the
most stunning feature of
Google TV hardware is
the video decoder.
It's really not easy to decode
Blu-Ray quality, streaming,
encrypted video files, and push
30 frames per second at 8
megabytes per frame through
HDMI to the television.
So there's a lot of video
processing going
on under the hood.
We really want Google TV to be
the primary reference for how
to deliver streaming video over
the internet, and we put
a lot of effort into that.
That also includes things like
state-of-the-art content
protection.
We know that movies
are expensive.
People who produce movies would
like to license them,
and would like to make
money on them.
We want to help them
and make sure that
their content is secure.
And we want to make sure that
users get access to the most
high-quality video content.
So we have PlayReady, we have
Widevine, we have HLS with AES
encryption.
So there's a lot of different
choices for video delivery.
CRISPY: And on top of that, you
can monitor the stream of
video live, right?
That takes additional tooling
and is going to
consume more memory.
QOS API is what I'm
getting at there.
CHRISTIAN: Lots of stuff.
CRISPY: So the chipset, there
are significant differences,
but part of that is
also isolated.
CHRISTIAN: Yeah, for a user,
basically the user interface
is you give us a stream URL and
you kick off playback, and
then the developer can sit back
and, as Crispy said, can
monitor the quality.
But all the decoding goes
on behind the scenes.
But that is one of
the differences.
People sometimes say, well hey,
I have a Raspberry Pi, it
runs Android.
I don't know if this one has a
HDMI out, but some of the ARM
devices have HDMI out.
But there is a reason Google
TV is really optimized for
television.
We have a lot of decoders.
CRISPY: We have dedicated
hardware that is not available
on any other Android device.
Period.
I'm sure people are going to
start trying to strap on FMPG
chips to their devices
at some point.
Leon, maybe that's your
next project.
All right, I think we've
covered that part of it
significantly.
We have one other part
to this question.
"Does Ice Cream Sandwich and
Jelly Bean improve performance
in any way?
Does it make use of these new
hardware capabilities?"
LES VOGEL: Yes.
If they ever exist.
CRISPY: If they ever exist.
CHRISTIAN: Well, we already use
the hardware codex, the
video codex.
So we do that pretty
efficiently.
I can't comment about Ice Cream
Sandwich or Jelly Bean
or anything else.
CRISPY: Nothing to announce
at this time.
LES VOGEL: We need a little
cardboard sign.
CRISPY: I made shirts for
us, do you remember?
LES VOGEL: That's right,
I should have
worn my shirt today.
CRISPY: Yes.
I'l lhave to make more funny
shirts like that.
LES VOGEL: Ice Cream Sandwich
and Jelly Bean run faster on
an Android phone.
So you can expect that when--
since we did announce that we
were going that direction
at I/O--
when that happens, it
will be faster.
CRISPY: That's true.
LES VOGEL: Christian's
so good.
CHRISTIAN: I'm just sitting
here smiling.
LES VOGEL: So, so good.
CRISPY: Like I said, he was
brought in to look pretty
today, right?
So "Is designing for Google TV
different than from tablet?
What do I need to keep in mind
while designing the UI for
Google TV?" Well,
fundamentally, no touch screen.
We've already touched on
a lot of these points.
The user's a lot farther from
the screen, except in Korea
where apparently they sit
inches from the screen.
LES VOGEL: 5 feet.
CRISPY: Pardon?
LES VOGEL: 5 feet is what
we've been saying.
CRISPY: Oh, OK.
Not inches, gotcha.
LES VOGEL: Not inches.
And it would be in meters.
CRISPY: Right, metric.
So the input devices
are different.
Obviously, no touchpad means
D-pad, and trackpad to a
limited degree.
And I think the LG has gesture
control, kind of.
It's in development,
it kind of works.
You want to consider
less information
density on the screen.
While they are physically
bigger, you're farther away,
which makes things
look smaller.
We've covered these things.
Vertical scrolling versus
horizontal scrolling, nobody
likes an infinite drop into hell
while looking for that
thing that they're trying to
watch, so consider your
navigation paths carefully.
Brightness and color, don't
flood the living room with a
whole bunch of white light.
Make sure you're not using
strong reds on a white
background, the color
vibration.
We have guidelines for this.
If you go to
developers.google.com/TV,
there's a section on
designing for TV.
I highly recommend
looking at that.
We've also got presentations
we've given.
They're peppered around
in various sources.
Good source to ramp
up on this.
And I think we're going to be
releasing some stuff on Google
Developer Academy soon that
covers some of this stuff--
porting tablet apps to TV.
All right, I think we're down
to the last one question.
Yes, we are.
"Hello, I'm looking for some
insight on how an application
I created and installed on
Google TV can determine what
other apps are on
the platform.
If my app determines what other
apps are on the box, can
my app launch them?
Can my app be instructed
to launch
them via Anymote Protocols?
LES VOGEL: You can use the
Process Manager, I believe,
and the Package Manager--
CRISPY: Package Manager, yeah.
LES VOGEL: --to figure
out what's on there.
You can send intents to apps.
Almost all of them
respond to Open.
And you can check out
openintents.org to see if the
app you're interested
in actually
has published methods.
And lastly, you can't send
from Anymote on a TV.
And that has to do
with pairing.
CHRISTIAN: But if you're already
running on the TV,
then intents is really
the intended
Android way to do this.
LES VOGEL: Exactly.
CRISPY: So I think one thing
I'm going to add to--
LEON NICHOLLS: [INAUDIBLE]
on your app.
CRISPY: Go ahead.
LEON NICHOLLS: I was just
saying, [? we built ?] all of
that in our apps, so it is
technically possible.
CRISPY: So with the Package
Manager, when you're looking
for the applications that are
on the system, I think you
want to consider filtering by
which applications have a main
launcher, or have a launcher
portion to them.
Just to save yourself loading
or looking through lists of
system services and other things
that you wouldn't want
to launch directly.
That would be my only
add-on to that.
Again, if you check out the
Android home screen sample,
there's code in there that shows
how to scan the system
for launchable applications,
something I came across when
building my homescreen.
So anybody else have anything
to add to that?
Otherwise we're going to wrap it
up, I think, for this week.
And just a reminder to everybody
watching now and
going to be watching the future,
we are doing these
every two weeks now.
So the next one will be
I believe November 13?
Does that sound right?
CHRISTIAN: And it's not
going be on Halloween.
CRISPY: Yeah, it won't
be Halloween.
So I will be dressed in
traditional cowboy hat and
urban cowboy gear.
Or maybe I'll wear my "I have
nothing to announce at this
time" t-shirt.
So yes.
Hope you like the costume and
the cool hats, and hope you
got a lot of value out
of today's Hangout.
It's great to have
you, as always.
And we are signing off.
Thanks, Leon.